you were at a rally this weekend um you
joined uh
groups of students and chanted [ __ ] the
algorithm in protest against the
government's decision to use computer
generated exam grades
so you've been you've been chanting this
a lot in the morning meetings [ __ ] the
algorithm
and you know and that's why we tag every
video we do with andrew schultz to try
to catch his algorithm wave
so how was the protest how was it here
polter's protest was great and i just
love this because
we're at the point now where everyone's
gonna pro
you can protest and pretty soon there's
gonna be [ __ ] pancakes there's gonna be
a [ __ ] pancakes protest
yeah they're upset about the algorithm i
don't know why because it's
computer-generated grades and they'd
rather have somebody to give them a hug
and hear their opinion you know and so
they can just go
listen this whole system is racist
everything's racist you gave me a b
because it was racist and it was also
sexist
and so this b doesn't work and this
algorithm is also [ __ ] up
and everything everything everything
everything is unnoticed
no notice the algorithm is systemically
racist yeah the algorithm they're
putting the [ __ ] algorithm on
can we just hear the [ __ ] the algorithm
chant because it's real fun because the
algorithm is on [ __ ] notice
there just comes a point where you
you crush civilization so hard and
everyone has burgers
that like the only thing left to
complain about is something that makes
our lives
infinitely easier the algorithm you want
this ikea bed
well then you may want this lamp as well
[ __ ] that thing
it's what it is and i think most of the
people at these protests don't even care
it's mob mentality they just don't you
know
five years ago why did i even do that
why was i chanting [ __ ] the algorithm
it's just all stupidity but what can you
do it gives us something to talk about
really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it
and go to patreon.com where things get
really wild
[Music]